last night in alabama yes i would
first of all say it's a shame
that we have to do this
it's really despicable
it's despicable that somebody can say
things about somebody and an organ more
importantly 17 year old kids they're
taking shots at 17 year old kids and
their families and they broke state laws
they're all money we bought every player
on this group we never bought anybody no
rules were broken nothing was done wrong
it was all and the way we do things the
ethics in which we do things and these
families it's despicable that a
republican head coach could come out and
say this when he doesn't get his way or
things don't go his way the narcissist
in him doesn't allow those things to
happen it's ridiculous but when when
he's not on top and the parody in
college football he's been talking about
go talk to coaches who coach for him
you'll find out all the parody go dig
into wherever he's been you can find out
anything and it's a shame that you got
to sit here and defend 17 year old kids
and families and texas a m because we do
things right we're always going to do
things right but we're always going to
be here
we're doing a heck of a job these
coaches have done a great job our
players have done a great job the whole
organization of recruiting people it's
despicable that we've got to sit at this
level the ball
and and say these things to defend the
people of this organization the kids 17
year old kids and their families
it's amazing
some people think they're god
go dig into how god did his his deal you
may find out about a guy
a lot of things you don't want to know
we build him up to be the czar of
football go dig into his past or anybody
ever coach with him you can find out
anything you want to find out
what he does and how he does it and it's
despicable
it really is and it's a shame we have to
sit up here and have this conversation
about things we do and it is personal to
us yes it is personal a m is personal to
our players the person with our coaches
and everybody involved and i know the
guy know him really well
it's amazing
that we're allowed to do those things
it's really despicable and i hate it for
our players who are coming here who did
things the right way have done things
the right way and will continue to do
things the right way i apologize to you
that people insult you publicly the way
they're doing it and our fans i
apologize to you guys for people saying
those things about texas a m i promise
you this there are no there are no
violations there are nothing wrong it's
the second time we've had to do this
with grown men who don't get their way
and want to pout throw a fit and act up
just go ask all the people who work for
him you'll know exactly what he's about
i always said this my dad always told me
this when people show you who they are
believe them
he's showing you who he is
questions
to the left olin
a couple of things jimbo first of all
have you had any contact with nick since
oh he's called
you just didn't take the call not going
to we're done
and uh he shows you who he is
and then i just wanted to he's the
greatest ever huh
and then i just wanted you got all the
advantages huh
it's easy
and i just wanted to
uh just put it point blank so
no players and you're you're saying that
no players there's nothing
anything we never promised done anything
that goes against the laws of the state
of texas and it's insulting to say a 17
year old and his family broke laws no
down front brent
you know y'all have both spoken so
highly of each other in the past in
terms of what y'all done in your
previous relationship so how
disappointing was it to hear that from
him you know in terms of you know a
mentor type yeah discipline no i wasn't
no listen you coach with people like
bobby bowden and learn how to do things
you coach with other people learn how
not to do things
there's a reason people don't